Hello World Saroj here.
Let's talk about five ways to use bitcoin.
The first way to use it is to make money transfer faster.
The current system of money transfer is centered around banks.
Even though Bitcoin doesn't require big account,
I'm still a fan of the idea of a big,
I'm not saying banks are a hundred percent trustworthy,
but I am saying I trust my mind enough to use it.
It provides security as service.
I can put all my money in my bank account and not have to worry that it will be
stolen because they built that trust over a long period of time with many,
many people.
I get a debit card and don't have to carry cash on me and if my card is stolen
and fraudulent charges are made,
my bank or funding,
it's great,
but one thing that my bank could do better is transfer money faster.
Bigs can use the bitcoin protocol to make money transfer instance.
For example,
international money transfer usually takes five business days.
That's because the banking system was designed pre-internet,
so money has to be routed to a bunch of different checkpoints before it reaches
the recipients.
The bitcoin protocol runs over the Internet to the recipient will receive your
money instantly to do this.
Banks can create their own internal cryptocurrency peg to their states currency.
Since bitcoin is so volatile,
so one bank coin could equal one US dollar always and bank queen could piggyback
off the speed and security of the bitcoin block chain to a user.
All transaction would occur in Derek currency of choice,
just like always,
they wouldn't even know it,
but under the hood,
this technology would not only make money transfer instance,
it would also allow you to send money to directly to bitcoin addresses,
not just traditional bank accounts.
I mean,
not everyone has the privilege of having trustworthy banks in their country,
particularly in the developing world.
A third of the world's adult population doesn't have a bank account in
developing countries.
Financial infrastructure can be totally,
totally absent.
People need bank accounts to participate in the global economy to get paid and
access loans and build credit.
The coin makes a barrier to entry for getting a bank account,
zero open a bitcoin wallet,
and you're good to go.
The bitcoin protocol can increase the region who we can send and receive money
from.
Not just people with traditional bank accounts,
but people would stand alone.
Bitcoin addresses as well.
Basically,
anybody with a phone can have what is essentially a bank account in their
pocket.
That's pretty cool,
right?
The second way to use it is to make it easier to earn money online.
Online transactions involving traditional currency involved transfer foods,
which means you can't really pay people a few cents at a time because the
payment would be lower than the fee itself.
Bitcoin allows people to get paid with really,
really small amounts or micropayments.
Since the transaction fee is almost nonexistent.
That means instead of being paid every two weeks at your job,
you could be able to get paid by the power minutes or even seconds.
People could page other fractions of pennies for data,
whether that be images or videos or articles,
whatever.
So if you were to write the song and posted on the Internet,
you could ask people to give you 1 cents or even half a cent per view and
bitcoin finally makes this possible.
The third way to use it is to help grow your startup.
Let's say you want to start a startup.
You create a product and incorporate your company.
Now you just need to raise money to get started.
Crowdfunding could be a cool idea,
but people might not be as likely to invest in you if all they get is a free tee
shirt.
What if you could reward people with equity or shares in your company using
bitcoin?
You could create your own currency with a few clicks and you can think of your
coins,
this shares and your company.
Each share would be linked to one coin.
You can give them out to people who back you early on or early adopters.
The value of your coins and grow as the value of your company grows,
just like in a traditional corporation to not just crowd funding the crowd
equity.
It's like an IPO,
but on day one it'll allow you to raise money much faster and since people will
be more invested in your company succeeding,
you get much more exposure,
but the possibilities don't end there.
Advances in robotics and automation technology are increasing at an accelerating
rate.
Robots are going to replace a lot of humans for Labor based jobs,
and then the need for a social safety net for people will become more apparent.
Well,
micropayments will allow people to get paid for their data if might not be
enough to fulfill their basic needs entirely,
which brings us to our fourth teams.
There could someday be a cryptocurrency that creates a global basic income.
That's right.
The cryptocurrency that gives people money for doing nothing.
We'd all be able to do whatever we want.
We'll all the robots do the word travel.
Do Research,
do drugs up.
Sorry.
No.
Anyway,
we need to find a way to prove one person could only create one account perhaps
by verifying existing government backed ids.
Then a consent.
Everyone who owned coins is small dividends every week just for existed,
and we could call it social coin.
There's so many possibilities.
I mean,
there had been many other cryptocurrencies created since bitcoin.
There's light coin and Doge coin and conduct am a God kind of pleased you head
to spotlight and all of them have their own unique features.
Like coin has faster transactions.
Bitcoin uses the computing power of its minors to solve scientific research
problems.
Zero Point makes transaction history,
privates.
The list goes on.
Our fifth use is efficiently connecting all monies.
The future of money is one where there is a thin layer of software around all
currency and we can just transact in the currency we're most familiar with and
take advantage of different currency features under the hood protocols like
stellar and to do just that.
Two of the biggest problems in the world war and poverty are directly linked to
the uneven distribution of wealth.
Global Bitcoin can help optimize how money is transferred across the planets and
make the world more safe and equal and free.
If you have more ideas on ways to use the coin,
please share them in the comments below.
I'd love to read them.
Thanks for watching.